This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. You have the desire to help a real difference? The College, LaCite, you offer the program Dependance and Sentental. Acquare the competences
essential for accompany and support the people confronted to the health and and dependents. Construise a career enriching
to service of the community Francophone of all the country. Don't the Coney in French,
it's possible with the CET. Visit CollageLac C.A. today, An initiative of the Consortium National
of Formation in Health Supporting, supported by Santee Canada. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. Evil, wake up.
I'm the woman that saw the murder take place by Krivac and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said, I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry in the Bone Valley feed on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
Joy is essential and it's also elusive, but now there's a new and exciting way to start your journey toward a more joyful existence, Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Joy 101 and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotfi is presented by CVS.
Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real, and genuine. Just honest conversations about what it means to be alive. I'm Javier Chichariot-O-Nandes
and listen to learning to be human. on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or whatever you get your podcast. Your husband is not who you think he is. Your body is not what you thought it was. Your identity is formed by a secret history. I'm Danny Shapiro. And these are just a few of the stunning stories I'll be exploring on the 14th season of Family Secrets.
He kind of shoved me out of the way and said, move. And he went out the front door and he jumped in a car and drove off. And that was the last time I saw him. Listen to season 14 of Family Secrets on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spake and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode. as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. I want to talk today about a situation or like the deep state of human longing that I receive
a whole lot of questions about and a whole lot of stories about all the time. Finding yourself kind of embroiled in a one-sided love affair with somebody who doesn't want you back. I get messages about this all the time and I got a message this week from a listener who has been in a situation like this for over two years with a co-worker of hers. She had like a brief kind of romantic encounter with him, like back in the day. They kind of went their separate ways after, like, he made the decision to break it off. But she was explaining to me, like even after he's gone and moved on, he's got a new girlfriend,
her attachment to him hasn't faded. And it's making it really hard to work. It's making it really hard to focus. The thing about this is, when you're in, in it, it feels all-consuming. And like you are the only person in the world who could be so silly or who is so stuck on somebody you know you can't be with. It feels like how rational, how strange that our minds cannot let somebody go despite all the reason in the world that this person is not right for us. But really, it is so much more common than you think. Maybe that doesn't make the
yearning hurt any less, but I think it does mean that we can offer a bit of an exercise. We can offer a bit of an explanation as to why this happens. From a more psychological angle, like there is a reason why we find ourselves so hooked on people we know we can't have. The very fact that we cannot have them is what deepens this obsession so much. And there's science and evidence to prove why that is. It may feel like so frustrating and annoying and heartbreaking at times. But I think understanding the biological underpinnings of this, the social underpinnings, the psychological underpinnings is really important. So that's what we're going to talk about today, as well as some strategies to kind of move through this situation of unrequited love and to essentially
understand why you have found yourself perhaps in a pattern of wanting people who don't want you, because there is a lot to be said about our motivations behind this and why we end up finding ourselves in these relationships maybe all too often. So without further ado, let's get into it. If you want to understand why we want the people who don't want us, you have to understand the psychology and more specifically the biology of the chase. At its very core, our attraction, to somebody else is not just emotional. It is a deeply chemical experience driven by some powerful neurotransmitters you're probably very familiar with, things like dopamine, serotonin, adrenaline, just to name a few. When we first meet somebody and feel like a romantic sensation,
kind of blossoming, our brain is just like flooded with feel-goody chemicals. and feelings which tell us to pursue this person, fixate on them, think about them, win them over, make them the object of our desire. We have a natural biological drive towards love because we are social beings and we crave partnership, we crave being seen, we crave creating these strong bonds. Now when the person reciprocates our feelings, we have a fabulous equation where the chemicals are flowing steadily from both sides, from them to you, you to them. There's no confusion, but just rewarded by their behavior and you're rewarded by what it feels like to belong and feel, I don't know, chosen by somebody. This feels good. Love obviously feels good. But when
somebody doesn't reciprocate our interest, this feels addictive. Here's the thing most people don't tell you about dopamine. It's not actually the happiness or pleasure chemical. It's the anticipation chemical. There's this wonderful 2010 paper, which talks about how dopamine doesn't spike when we get something. It spikes in the pursuit of something. It drives craving. It drives our motivation to chase, to pursue, to impulse by, to want the cookie, to anticipate the reward, to like the person who doesn't like us back. This means it can be very easily hijacked when we are yearning or longing for something because we're getting these massive dopamine spikes that aren't met with the reward or fulfillment of the desire.
This is quite literally the chemical basis of addiction, wanting something, needing something, desiring it deeply to the point where it's all we can think about, not receiving it, crashing or receiving it and feeling even better, but then needing more. Now, when somebody doesn't like you back, but you occasionally see them around, like they occasionally like your Instagram stories, you have like somewhat of a history where maybe they once showed you affection, now they don't anymore. What you're essentially experiencing is something called intermittent reinforcement. You occasionally get interactions, spikes of what you want, what could be. And that sets off your dopamine systems because they already have a low,
a low threshold. And it makes you feel really, really good. There's like these little spikes followed by these big crashes. But the anticipation of, or the expectations of things changing, the anticipation that your next interaction, your next moment could be the moment when things, they fall in love with you, keeps you hooked. Each small signal of attention, a text, a glance, a moment of connection feels disproportionately rewarding because it's unpredictable. That inconsistency actually strengthens the attachment. Over time, your brain, like you're in such a heightened state of craving that it feels like genuine attraction. The anxiety, the obsession, the excitement, it's so intense that intensity obviously registers deeply with our brain,
and therefore it can be mistaken for actual chemistry and for something that's very, very real to your mind, even if rationally you know it's not. But what you're often experiencing is not a real connection, it's a loop. Uncertainty, again, creates anticipation, anticipation releases dopamine, dopamine increases desire, the lack of resolution keeps the cycle going. I just want to really like make this a core point. Your inability to move on from this person, even though you know there's no future, even though you know they don't feel the same way, is not because you lack willpower. It's because there are insanely powerful chemical loops bringing you back again and again and again, hoping, expecting, wanting a different outcome.
So you are biologically being hijacked by this kind of relationship. It is a relationship. There's another reason we want people who don't want us back. It's the promise of the ultimate self-worth achievement. If they were to eventually want us back, everyone who has ever rejected us, every bad feeling we have about ourselves, every moment of unrequited love, Every second we've doubted ourselves, it would all be proven false. We would finally have confirmation that we were good enough for somebody, that we can prove ourselves to somebody who initially dismissed us, that we do have value, that somebody does want us.
The thing is, the person who doesn't want us holds all the power right now. Like they hold all the power because we can't give ourselves the validation of being wanted by somebody else, especially not by them. Like only they can give us that. Of course, we can like think that we're great. But we think that they're wonderful. We think that they're an amazing person. Like if we like somebody, we obviously have a great opinion of them.
We think they have good taste. We think they're cool. So them not liking us feels like we didn't make the cut based on their standards. We must not be all that good in the eyes of this great individual. This cuts really deep to the core of our own self-acceptance and worth assessment. Deep down, if this person has rejected us, we believe that means they must see themselves as better than us or deserving of more, or deserving of somebody who is, or of having standards that we can't meet. The thing is, this obviously makes us feel awful, right? Because we don't feel
like we made the cut. It also creates a strange competitiveness in us, whereby if we were to eventually convince them to like us, this would prove that we must be good. we must be worth something. That's a great feeling to be striving for. I fully believe people who are high achievers, very ambitious, very smart, fall a lot harder for unrequited love. I know I've said it before. It's genuinely a hill I will die on. You are so used to having to work for anything that you want, to having to put in long hours, to strive. You may even live by the philosophy that like anything worth having won't be easily. So why wouldn't that be the same for love? You feel that way for work. You feel that way in your ambition at school in your goals. This belief
transfers over to relationships as well. If it's easy, it's not worth it because things that are quality make you work harder. So that's why we don't want the person who wants us. They didn't make us work hard for it. We want the person who obviously has value because it's not immediately accessible. That doesn't apply to love though, right? Our mind is taking a standard we set for everything else and being like, well, this must be the same here. Love is something that is actually and should probably flow very naturally compared to everything else in life that makes us really work and strive and sweat. There's also this concept in psychoanalytic psychology that I really think you should know called the object of desire. This was first discussed by a French psychologist
called Jacques Lacan. Hopefully my French accent is good. His idea is that when we see something we can't obtain, whether that is an expensive house on Zillow, a lifestyle of an influencer, or a person who we think is great, we begin to project this idea that this is where happiness, self-worth, fulfillment must be. This thing, this is the thing that would make us happy. And the fact we don't have it is why we're unhappy. It kind of gives us a reason for our insecurity, a reason for our sadness, our lack of fulfillment that isn't internal. Like, it's not because we're doing something wrong. It's not because we're unhappy. It's because we're missing this thing. And once we have this thing, all of our wildest dreams will come true. This is a big explanation for why we long and why
we yearn. We know we'll never have this thing. And therefore, it's easy to place all of our hopes and desires and long-loss wishes like at its feet. A person, a relationship, especially when we know we cannot have is like the perfect candidate for this elusive role of representing everything that would fix our lives for us because love is painted that way is something that is everything. I also think that the very fact that this person doesn't want us makes them mysterious and that mystery means we can create whatever fantasy we want of them. You know, they're flawless in our minds. We actually, because we aren't around them as much because we don't have a relationship,
Like, we can create whatever fantasy version of a soulmate we want, even if it's not real. Like, we can build them into whatever we want them to be. And the sides of somebody that are only revealed in a relationship, the sides that are kind of ugly or not likable, those aren't there. And so our obsession only deepens because we believe we found the last person on earth who might actually be perfect. the idealized version of somebody that is that you are at a distance from, it's a lot easier to love and a lot easier to be obsessed with. The thing is, if you were to get to know them,
they probably wouldn't be like that. But when somebody is distant or unavailable, they remain undefined. And undefined people can be come, be present, be seen as anything we want them to be. So that makes it a lot harder to move on. There are a few other explanations for why unrequited love keeps us hooked. Obviously attachment theory is a big one. I'm not going to talk about it today though because I just feel like we've done so many episodes on it that you can go and find. I just feel like it's such a big topic.
The other thing though and the other big explanation is this one particular effect I don't see people talking about, which is the zygarnic effect. Zygarnic effect. our brain hates unfinished stories. And so our brain will keep them open until we get the solution. This means we genuinely cannot move on until we feel like we have closure. Until we know why they don't want us. We know that somebody else will.
This is what is happening when you want somebody who, and you find yourself wanting them more after they don't want you back. Like they've done studies on this where they'll get somebody to do a task and they'll interrupt them halfway through and then they'll get them to do another task. and this person will be like, I can't do this. I'm fixated. I'm fixated on finishing this unfinished thing. And that is literally what happens with relationships that are unfinished as well. How can I move on when this door isn't being officially closed? And finally, I also think unrequited love gives us a purpose. When everything else in your life feels uncertain, having text to analyze, small moments to replay,
somebody to yearn for gives you like the greatest kind of object to fixate on. It feels so important because like what's more important than love? It's an amazing, amazing distraction. Not having that someone, that fixation point can make life feel kind of boring and meaningless. And so sometimes our obsession with somebody is rather grounding. It's purpose giving. It's motivating, especially when, you know, you are a little bit lonely. You're struggling with work. You don't really have a purpose. It's like, well, why does that matter if I have this?
If I can win this person over, it's all going to be okay. Love is like the best thing out there. If I find love, all of this other stuff is going to take care of itself. So that's the explanation for why you find yourself in the state of limerence and obsession with an unrequited figure, why somebody not liking you back is so, like, deeply powerful for our brain. Let's continue this conversation and talk about what to do about it, including some more controversial advice I have for you.
Stay with us. You have the desire to help us? The College, the Citi, you offer the program Dependence and Sentental Mental. Acquare the competences essential for accompany and support the people confronted to health mental and dependence. Construise a career enriching
to service of the community francophone of all the country. Don't know their quality in French, it's possible with The City. Visit the Collage Latcate.C.A. right now.
An initiative of the Consortium National of Formation in Health in Canada. In the moment, it felt like it was going on forever.
I didn't think I was going to live. I was terrified. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell
out of me. That was your first murder case? Yes, yeah. Fear to say this was the biggest case of your career? Yes, sir. Rape and murder for a child. Just as bad as it gets. I would think so.
Evil, wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Crevent and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
And to hear the devil's quarry ad free with exclusive content, subscribe to LaVa for Good Plus on Apple Podcasts. Hey, I'm Hoda Kotby, host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby. Together, we're going to have meaningful conversations with the world's most fascinating people, like when actress Olivia Munn shared how she overcame fierce health challenges. I've gone through breast cancer and then helped my mother through breast cancer, and that was more difficult. There's a lot of people who understand postpartum depression.
I was not prepared for postpartum anxiety. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. And it's a part of it's exciting because their new star is Javier Ticharito Hernandez. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day, I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions, ever since I was born. And I still have so many questions. Where do we come from? What happens after death?
How do you deal with cancellation? Cristiano or Messi? Do aliens exist? What is love? Real Madrid or Barcelona? From every day and ordinary to the deep and extraordinary. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real and genuine.
This podcast is like a deep talk with your closest friends. Where vulnerability comes out. Conspiracy theories end up on the table and goals and lessons are shared. All in this life has a order perfect and everything is just. Wait me, I'm going to pressur me, but me will go to go back. We are here to connect. El Chicharito. And together with Iha Radio, we're going to make the ordinary, extraordinary.
Stay close. It's a crack. Wow. Listen to learning to be human or IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or whatever you get your podcast. Here's something that should not be as complicated as it is. Getting a racist statue removed. And here's something that should be a whole lot easier than it is. getting a new one put up in its place.
As long as there's a politics of race in America, there's going to be a politics of remembering the civil war. To get to school, I had to go down Robert Lee Boulevard. Get to the grocery store, I had to go down Jefferson Davis Parkway. If you're an historian and you leave out half of what the history is, you're not doing your job. I'm Akila Hughes, and Rebel Spirit Season 2 goes deep on both of those things. The fights, the politics, the people who won,
and my personal campaign to add something to the Kentucky State House that's actually worth the wall space. We are more than our bodies. We contain essence. We contain spirit. How do you represent that? They are just fueling a fire that is really catching. You'll see what I mean.
Listen to Rebel Spirit Season 2 on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Okay, hear me out. There is nothing wrong with a fun, a fun little crush. Honestly, I think it's a soul need. I think it's probably good for the soul. to feel hopeful about the state of love and hopeful that there are people out there who you would want to meet and get to know and fall for. I read this really great psychology today piece that
talks about how crushes make us feel excited. They keep us caring about how we present to the world, which is probably important from an evolutionary perspective. They keep us optimistic. They're also just like once again, they're fun. Like a crush is fun and that can be all that it is. liking somebody that you know, like you have no intention of actually ever doing anything about it. Like, you have no intention of like asking them out. Like, it's, it's not that serious. Like, that's fun. It's like what being in your 20s is about. Um, that's when I personally think, like, situations like this are okay. Like, you know they're not going to hurt you because they don't want you back so you can kind of just observe. But when they dance into like dangerous territory
emotionally is when we encounter this like objective desire situation where once again, we think of them as the savior, we put our first name next to their last name, like we lose ourselves to our obsession. What they do, how they choose to treat us, whether we see them or not, dictates our entire emotional state. And we do just silly things. I've been there. I've done so many silly things for people who've never showed any interest in me.
And that is a problem and that does require some examination. And this is when we need to break the spell. here's how I think we should go about it or you should go about it based on some of the psychological principles, the same psychological principles that got you hooked in the first pace. Identify firstly what it is about them that they represent that you think you are otherwise missing. Unrequited love is rarely just about the person. It's about what they symbolize.
When you feel intensely drawn to somebody who doesn't want you back, your brain isn't just responding to them as an individual. It's responding to what they represent in your psychological world that is absent. This is a concept closely, closely tied to Freud's concept of projection and idealization. Again, as we said before, we take the qualities we admire, we crave, we feel only lack, we place them in this other person, and in that way we turn them into an emotional solution. We turn them into like the golden band-aid. maybe what you're lacking and the reason you're attracted to this person is because you're not
confident and this person is so confident so you feel like if they were to be with you you'd finally feel good about yourself the thing is if your self-esteem were to improve if you were to realize how amazing you actually are your need and desire for them you would be surprised by how quickly it would disappear maybe what you're lacking is a sense of security right now we just spoke about this, but this person might represent what it would feel like to have certainty in your life or in a partner. And it kind of like not have to worry about it anymore. You've got your person, it's all sorted. And you're just really craving something that is certain, something that is going to go right and that is secure. Maybe what they represent is again a purpose, which you otherwise feel
you don't have. There's so many things that somebody else can represent. They can represent excitement, they can represent belonging, they can embody the kind of person you want to be. And like, so by, by admiring them from afar, sometimes what's happening is you unconsciously feel closer to this ideal version of you through your like temporary one-sided attachment to them. What are you seeking to fulfill? What does this person offer that you don't think you can offer yourself right now? There's this theory called the self-expansion model.
I don't know if it's a self-expansion model full stop or self-expansion model of love, but it was like one of the first psychological theories of love. And it essentially says we are mainly attracted to people that grow and expand our sense of self and that who we think would make us better people. So it's not wrong that you want this person who you think would make you better or who you think is great and has resources and has a great personality and it's cool. That's not wrong. It's actually probably why you like that. them in the first place. But what's to say you aren't capable of self-expansion through friendship right now, through your own self-exploration, through mentorship, or through somebody else
that actually wants you? We get fixated on this person thinking that they're the only ones who can expand us for getting all these other options. When you identify what you think it is that this person would fulfill what need or absence you need them for, you can get to work kind of feeling it in other ways. Secondly, it's a important to like create physical distance in any way that you can and just flush this person out with as many hobbies like social engagements opportunities as you can now some people would say this is just plain or distraction maybe it's even avoidance like i see the argument and i would agree with them because it kind of is that's the whole point like it is distraction it is trying to
get away from the problem and the initial months of trying to move past this person you need to be continuously breaking the association between them and the feeling of anticipation and dopamine. Basically, that's what we need to do. What you're experiencing when you get a rush or a thrill anytime you see them, hear from them, think about them is a conditional emotional response. So you need to focus on extinguishing that by, well, extinguishing that response by creating more powerful ones and also by not giving into the desire to reach out or to see them or to be with them. From a psychological perspective, this has a name, it's called extinction.
Basically, when a learned association weakens because the expected reward is no longer delivered, like we stop anticipating it. The thing is extinction doesn't happen just like because passively. Like if you just sit in the absence, your brain often actually increases craving in an attempt to motivate you to get the reward back. that's why people relapse, that's why they text them, that's why they check their socials or they spiral, when they just think that ignoring them is extinguishing the connection, instead you have to actively compete with the old association and give your brain new sources of reward,
new people who give you connection without anxiety, more social things in your day, connecting with old friends, making new friends, activities, adventures, side quests that, like, create genuine dopamine, novelty, like creativity, planning for something, training for something, reaching for a goal, being in environments that don't carry their memory. It's also important to understand that, again, I want to really state this, this kind of distraction is very different from long-term emotional avoidance. You're allowed, I think, in these moments to still think about them, you're not suppressing or denying your feelings forever. You're just creating enough distance so that the intensity is manageable and so that you know that they are not the only thing
that's going to make you happy or make you fulfilled. Once the emotional charge is lower, you can reflect more clearly. You can process what actually happened. And you can understand the dynamic without being pulled back into it, I think, as well. The next thing I do, I haven't done it in a while, but I think it's absolutely essential. Have an imaginary breakup day where you do everything you do if you had actually been in a relationship with this person and broken up. Take a sick day, go out for a long, sad walk in the woods, or in nature, write them a long letter, have a hot shower, cry, eat ice cream, drink some wine, watch La La Land, cry some
more. Grieve them in the way that you deserve to. basically like have a funeral for the love story that you imagined with them, this person. This is so effective. It's so effective because it essentially creates the ending to counteract the zygonic effect. Like we spoke about this before, like that unended story, your brain operates best when a story has a beginning. It has a middle or a lesson. and it has an end.
For unrequited love, you don't get the end. So you have to provide it for yourself in order to then move forward and discover the lesson as to why this particular individual is so desirable to you. When you give yourself a day to properly, intentionally, grieve, be dramatic, even if you don't think you deserve to, like just do it. You're doing something very psychologically sophisticated. You're taking something abstract and unresolved, which is this connection, this one-sided connection,
and you're making it concrete, you're saying this happened, this was real, and you're giving it a finale. You are ritualizing something that would otherwise feel very confusing. You are giving it the ending that you deserve and that your brain needs to clearly see in order to move forward. Finally, once you've provided yourself with the ending, this is when you can start to reframe the situation from loss, interlesson. And I know that sounds corny. But I think creating an ending is one level of moving forward.
Finding the meaning is the next level and is what allows us to integrate this experience. And really, it's what allows us to grow as individuals, which probably doesn't sound very meaningful to you right now, but is very important. Instead of asking, like, why didn't this work out? What's wrong with me? Like, what's wrong with me? You start asking. more constructive questions. Like, what did this actually reveal about what I need in a future person? What patterns did this bring to the surface? What am I being shown about my standards, my attachment style that doesn't sit right with me? What do I need to concentrate on within before I date somebody else or have another crush? This shift is really powerful because it transforms you
from just being a passive participant who was hurt, who was kind of a victim of this person's decisions into an active interpreter of your experience and somebody who also, you have something to gain in the aftermath of this. You are not just somebody who was a victim, who lost, you left with a deeper connection to yourself and to your needs and your desires. And some people never get that. They are never challenged to look past attraction. It also prevents repetition. When you extract the lesson, you're far less likely to have to learn the lesson again and to chase the same dynamic because you understand what drew you to that person in the first place. I found that with the last person I dated before Tom.
I had like three or four of the same exact kind of semi-relationships back-to-back. And I don't think, like, well, I know I didn't actually sit with what they meant. Like I did the ritual of closing the chapter. I grieved. But I never was like, hey, maybe there's a pattern here. Like, maybe I'm just doing the same things and expecting. a different outcome. Finally doing that with the last guy is why I think I have the relationship I have now, because I was able to see, like, these people are literally the same people. This was the same
relationship. I just did it four times. I didn't learn the lesson. I will say, my final point on this, don't be unkind to yourself about the situation. Honestly, I think people who give and give and give love and are open to everybody and see the best in people and genuinely, like, care and love and have their heart on the line are what we need more of. As much as there are all these rules these days, and, like, there's this kind of idea that, like, to be successful in dating, you have to be cold and heartless. Humans aren't meant to despise love. They're not meant to be rational about love either. Like, that's been way too normalized, that we're meant to be these, like, cold professionals. situations of unrequited love and yearning and longing are one of the most human things you can
experience. Like personally, I think it's spiritual almost. And I'd much rather, and I'd much rather you are, somebody who feels and loves deeply and gives deeply, even if that is unrecyclicated, then be somebody who cannot find it in their heart to care or who sees love as a game or who sees love as something to win and there are rules to follow and the first one to fall in love loses. Like, I don't think that's particularly healthy. As much as people talk about how unrequited love is, like, I don't know, unhealthy and irrational and as much as it probably is really frustrating and, like, goes against many forms of, like, reasoning, is it really that bad to, like, care deeply about somebody and to see somebody's potential? Like, I think that the
fact that you have that capacity for somebody who doesn't care about you means that when you find somebody who really does care about you and you feel this way about them as well, you're going to experience like a whole other depth. Like you think this is love. Imagine what love is going to feel like when you have that level of reciprocation. But I only think you can get there if you break this current bond and if you are able to investigate, and kind of reveal to yourself what it is about somebody who doesn't want you back that is so captivating to you. Is it the sense of achievement?
Is it that you think you need to earn love? Is it that they are representing a disregarded need that you have? I don't know, I can't really give you the answers, but I hope that, yeah, I hope that this is helpful. I hope that this information can get you a little bit closer. So that is our summary on why we love the people who do not love us back. And I've been there many, many times. So I feel for you.
And I hope that, I hope you know that, like, you do get through it. And you get through it in the way that you just, eventually you just realize how valuable that lesson is. And you feel really grateful that you had the opportunity to feel that way about anybody, even somebody who, like, didn't return the feeling because it's kind of spectacular. So I don't know if that's helpful if you're going through it right now, but it's just, I don't know, it's something that I wish I'd heard. So if you've made it this far, do me a favor. Leave a comment down below, what breakup movie are you going to watch tonight?
Or what breakup movie are you going to watch for the funeral of this could have been, what if relationship? I want to know. Mine was always La La Land. I've heard great things. about Notting Hill. Notting Hill, yeah, Notting Hill, the notebook, drop yours below, I guess those weren't stories of unrequited love, but La La La Land kind of was, and I think it's a great one. You can also follow us on Instagram. You can share this episode with a friend if you think they need to hear it. And if you didn't know, you can watch full episodes like this one on Netflix. Yeah, that's right. Netflix all over the world. If you want to watch a video version of this podcast, that is where you can find us.
There's so many other links including, yeah, there's just so many other links in the description that you can check out. I feel for you. I'm sure you're really going through it right now, but it does get better. And yeah, I'm wishing you a lot of love and a lot of luck. But until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black.
It scared the hell out of me. Evil, wait. up. I'm the woman saw the murder take place by Crevec and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said, I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry in the Bone Valley Feed on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Joy is essential and it's also elusive. But now, there's a new and,
an exciting way to start your journey toward a more joyful existence. Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Joy 101 and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby is presented by CVS.
Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions, ever since I was born. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real, and genuine. Just honest conversations about what it means to be alive. I'm Javier Tornandez and listen to Learning to Be Human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or whatever you get your podcast. Your husband is not who you think he is. Your body is not what you thought it was.
Your identity is formed by a secret history. I'm Danny Shapiro. These are just a few of the stunning stories I'll be exploring on the 14th season of Family Secrets. He kind of shoved me out of the way and said, move. And he went out the front door and he jumped in a car and drove off. And that was the last time I saw him. Listen to Season 14 of Family Secrets on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. June is Black Music Month.
And on the Drink Chams podcast, we're speaking with the hottest names in the culture, like Sway Lee. Do you realize how legendary you are? I appreciate that. I'd be seeing it, but I'm like, man, I still got, like, so much more to do. Like, Prince, he dropped, like, 30 albums. We dropped, like, five right now. That's the rate we got to be going. Yep, that's a good attitude.
No matter the era, Drink Chams brings you the biggest names and the most unfiltered conversations. Listen to Drink Chams from the Black Effect Podcast Network on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.